The BBC series
Natural World filmed a segment
where Kangaroo Dundee--
no relation--
fed a wombat an ear of corn,
which is now my new favorite
euphemism for sex.
Unfortunately, Pete the wombat
was not on board.
So, comedians,
how does he react?
He screams like
a death metal singer,
he chomps into
the handsome man's nose,
or he rips a fart?
Uh, Mark.
A-- Screams like
a death metal singer.
Well, I guess that could be an
interpretation of what happens.
Let's take a listen.
Um, want some?
Want a treat?
-(wombat passes wind)
-Oh! -(laughter)
Wasn't me.
-(applause and cheering)
-(wombat passes wind)
-He farts just like us!
-HARDWICK: Yeah, yeah.
That could pass
for a human fart.
They... they fart...
MARON:
But now he's gonna be
-the farting wombat, like Grumpy
Cat. -HARDWICK: He's gonna...
It's like,
it's the farting wombat.
Gonna be a billionaire.
A Internet star is born!
You know, you guessed wrong,
but I'm still gonna give you
100 points
for the predicting the next big
Internet meme, Marc Maron.